- On this episode I
answer how to bookmarket.
We talked about elementary school students
and Wuzzles?
♫ Hey
(hip hop dance music)
♫ Gary Vee
♫ You ask questions
♫ Hey, and I answer them
♫ This is
♫ the #AskGaryVee Show♫
Hi everybody,
this is Gary Vay-ner-chuk
and this is episode 113
of The #AskGaryVee Show.
Super pumped up, nice day.
Been, you know was in Cannes, France,
so Cawn, Cannes, so didn't
get to do as many shows
as I wanted to at the end of last week.
Been missing a lot of you.
The best of #AskGaryVee Show,
I just watched the first
couple minutes of the edit
so I'm super excited about that.
We'll be releasing that
shortly, I'm around this week.
So we'll have a good amount of shows.
I'm even tryin' to sneak one in tomorrow.
I know Wednesday we're
firm, Thursday we're firm?
- [Voiceover] Yeah.
- Friday we firm?
- [Voiceover] No.
- No, so today, Wednesday, Thursday
so three definite this
week I'm just gonna try
to sneak in a fourth one.
What am I doing Friday?
- [India] It's Fourth of July.
- [DRock] Fourth of July.
- It's Fourth of July weekend
right, very good point
and I'm going to a wedding
so I'll be disappearing.
Cool, and yeah.
India,
(laughing)
let's get into the show.
By the way real quick,
real quick, I really like
that little message your dad sent you
about me ripping your ear.
- [India] Oh yeah.
My dad's a little concerned
- [Gary] Big ups to pops.
Sorry about that dad.
- [India] message about my ear
Yeah, well.
- [Gary] How's your ear?
- It's totally fine.
- Totally.
- Yeah.
- Okay I'm ready, I'm
really, I am super ready
for this show guys, I'm really
fired up, I'm really pumped.
I love this show, I love all of you.
- [Voiceover] Ronny asks
"If you had the opportunity
"to speak in front of an auditorium full
"of elementary schoolers,
what would be your topic
"of choice and why?"
- My topic of choice, so first of all
if I was in a room full of
elementary school students,
like I was once ever in my
career which was in Houston
in a tremendous conference that I went to
where it was the best students
from elementary school
of all of Houston and I
cursed up a storm and I talked
about like all sorts of crap.
I remember I tried to connect with them
so I was using like random hip
hop artists that were popping
at the time and the teachers
were literally flabbergasted
and completely pissed off and the kids
were completely pumped.
And like these were like
the greatest students
of like seventh and eighth
grade in all of Houston
and like a third of the class
quit school in seventh grade
when I was done with the talk.
Because what I really talked
to them about was real life
which is look you're a great student,
you're goin' down a
certain path right now.
Bad news, education in
America is screwing you over.
You're gonna pop out and
you're gonna realize holy crap
I don't wanna do this or this
and that and then I talked
about the virtues of good schooling.
Which is the randomness of
having a college roommate
that's a billionaire and some
of the other random stuff.
But you know it was a tremendous talk.
My choice of topic today,
if I was to do it today,
would be you know I would tell them
to really recognize how
to build self-esteem and self-awareness.
I would pound that and I would say look,
you're looking at me and
I'm an old dude up here
and I'm cliche just like all
your other teachers and parents
but you need to find the
things that you're good at
and really find the friends
that you're looking for
and you know you hear it a million times
that you're not gonna look back and care
about the dumb shit
that you care about now
but you don't believe me,
but that's not gonna stop me
from trying to pound it down
you're little f- throat.
- [India] Yes.
- Oh these are all the
Instagram questions.
- [India] Yeah.
- You got a lot of
questions from there right?
- [India] Yeah.
- So we can do a couple episodes
worth, cool that was fun.
Follow me on Instagram (fingers snap)
This whole notion of
like where is the time?
I think that people like to
claim that they work hard
and smart but they're
not putting in the work.
Your hustle, your work ethic,
your drive is not predicated
on your zip code.
♫ Think you do right.♫
(snaps fingers) Righthook,
that's a hashtag DRock.
- [DRock] Thank you.
Jimmy Fallon, Justin Timberlake.
- Oh that's right I forgot about that.
- [India] My question, is it possible
to have two burning passions and pursue...
- You know I was on
Jimmy Fallon once right?
- I'm here with the one and
only wine guru Gary Vaynerchuk
whose daily webcast The Thunder
Show on WineLibrary.com
attracts over at 90,000 viewers a day.
Very impressive buddy.
- Appreciate it.
- And you're a wine guru,
what makes you a wine guru?
Could you explain it a little bit?
- Self-proclaimed, you
know just take the title.
(laughing)
- [India] You're just being so silly.
- I'm in a very silly
mood today, it's a Monday.
- [India] I can tell.
- Yeah, I love Monday.
So it's early Monday morning
and I've been wanting
to make a Monday morning video
for a long time and finally
DRock we're doin' it.
So real quick, this is
just a rant, very simple
and something that I want you to pass on
or watch every Monday
morning because the level
of complaining is unacceptable.
Look (fingers snap).
(laughing) Yeah, Lotsa editing.
This is not gonna, we're
taping this so early
and it's gonna come out so late.
- [Voiceover] Pixel
art asks "Is it possible
"to have two burning
passions and pursue them
"at the same time without half-assing them?
"Or is it ideal to pick one at a time?"
- That's a really good question.
I, you know I think there's people
that have two burning
passions at the same time.
I really do and I wonder
if you can Wuzzle them
and make them both work at the same time.
That was a 1980's rare television cartoon
Saturday morning reference, Wuzzle.
Do you know what Wuzzles are?
India search it right now.
- [India] Wuzzles?
- Let's watch India's face
as, she's gonna love these
watch this, this is India in real time,
this is India in real time.
- Wuzzles?
- Yeah Wuzzles, W, yep see it?
- [India] Wuzzles?
- Uh-huh, go to images
because this is Wikipedia
go to images.
- [India] Okay.
- I want you to like really
wrap your head around
how cool these things are, cool right?
They're two animals in one.
So she was like a hippo
- [India] Oh.
- and a butterfly, you
see what's going on here?
two animals in one.
- [India] I see it, I see it.
Oh I kinda remember this.
- Bang that's what I
was lookin' for, uh huh.
- [India] The two animals in one.
- Uh-huh, so maybe you can
Wuzzle them right and find a way
to make your two passions...
For example, you know
I could've very easily
made Wine Library TV and the Jets..
What's goin' on to you?
- [India] (laughing) Wuzzle them.
- Well Wuzzle them, like
take your two passions
- [India] I know
- and smash them into one.
- [India] I get it.
- Like for example, I could've
done all my wine episodes
at football games that
would've been a further..
You know I have the
Jets bucket but you know
there's ways to uniquely...
I think you know I once
said and a lot of you liked
this photo on Instagram,
if you order this quote,
if you want to be an anomaly
you have to act like one.
I wonder based on this question
if you could be the first
person that combines two things
that nobody's ever combined
before which are weird and win.
For example again, I love wrestling.
What if I did Wine Library
TV only at tailgates
or football environments
and wrestling matches.
Like independent
circuits, like weird stuff
where there's 150 people
in the audience at a gym
and the Iron Sheik's still
there, you know stuff like that.
So I'm a big fan of trying
to find a way to Wuzzle them
and that's what I would do.
Now obviously a lot of
people are gonna tell you
pick one, focus, I may say that at times.
Today I felt like Wuzzling
them, tomorrow if I answer
this question I might say
pick one, both can work.
I think at the end of the
day, and we've talked a lot
about this, it's about self-awareness.
And it's funny I'm reading
every goddamn comment
in Facebook specifically, right now I'm
on a Facebook comment kind
of spree so I apologize
to all the YouTubers but
that's just what's happening,
and it's interesting I'm
feeling more and more pressure
on my shoulders more than ever before
because the show is
picking up so much momentum
and I'm watching so many people comment
about them implementing
and seeing results.
And it makes me hungry,
ambitious, greedy to try
to impact more people with
what is really working.
Which is if you really
know yourself, really India
this question comes down
to a very simple place
which is it's one of two choices.
It's truly one of two choices.
It's really just two
levers, it's happiness
and financial and street cred upside.
It's just trying to pull the lever..
and listen I do this, I think
a lot of you may be confused.
I leave enormous amounts
of money on the table
for happiness.
I just do, I do it all the time.
The largest speaking gig
of my career, a number
that makes me vomit on the
table out of happiness,
I passed on 'cause it's week
four and the Jets are playing
in London and I want to go
watch the Jets play the Dolphins
in London, and by the way
this is a significant number,
this is a hefty six figure deal.
This is more money than I
made in a three year period
in my mid-twenties to go
and MC and speak at an event
for a day and a half.
Still could've watched the
Jets like I do all the time
and I'm choosing happiness
over cash and we all
have to do that all the
time and our lives evolve.
I'm in a better financial place
than I was seven years ago.
Maybe then I would've
chose cash, I don't know,
but even in my early days..
For example, when I lost an
eighth of, eight Jesus Christ,
a third of my entire wealth in my twenties
to have fun in Vegas so I
then lose it all gambling
was 'cause I chose
happiness, kinda sadness,
over, over, over wealth.
And so the answer to this question
is predicated very simply.
Do I believe there's, I'm gonna
really, I'm really breakin'
this down India, if you
Wuzzle it you may pop
and be an anomaly and have
disproportionate success
'cause you're the first guy to ever bring
spaghetti and music together in this way.
Most likely you won't
and your financial upside
is probably predicated on
picking one and going all in.
Most likely, however, you
just might have more happiness
mixing the two and have the
home run grand slam potential
of breaking out which is why
I always do those things.
I'm always picking my
happiness versus the straight
and obvious course because
I've got a little bit of magic
and sometimes my weird
stuff actually works as well
and the booboo prize is that I'm happier.
And boy happiness is addicting.
You know what I'm gonna actually
throw a right hook here, right now.
- [Voiceover] Vayner Nation
Serious Right Hook war.
- I love Wuzzles, please
go to eBay and buy me
some stuffed animal Wuzzles
so I can put 'em right here on the show.
I'ts a very inexpensive way
for you to get a shoutout.
That's all in black and white.
I'm gonna start doing
more of that, I love eBay
and like garage sale culture
and I'm gonna start getting
the fans to buy me random shit.
(laughing)
I mean the shows free
you might as well pay
some sort of vig.
- [DRock] How about
a table full of Wuzzles?
- Yeah I just want tables full
of random crap collectibles.
Things that I want, then I
wanna flip 'em back on eBay
and make a profit on your ass.
- [Voiceover] Whadafunk asks,
"yo Gary V.
"Can you rate my Instagram
on a one to 10 scale
"and tell me how to improve?"
- Yeah, let's do it live.
India great job, great question
so here we are whadafunk
who I've seen plenty
of times in my stream.
So here's his clothing thing.
I don't, can you, can you,
what can you get here?
I'm gonna rate it here.
Let's see what's going on.
Not a lot of engagement.
- [Voiceover] Can you
turn up her brightness?
- Let's see, yeah.
- [India] It's the other way (laughs).
- Just kidding.
The pictures are tremendous,
let's play this video.
(hip hop music)
I love it, I love the ghettoness.
So, 1500 followers,
ten, 15, 20 engagements.
The engagements are a hair low.
I mean I really like the
photos I just, honestly,
I don't think you're
growth hacking enough.
I think you need a lot more of a fan base.
Whadafunk hangin' at my
homies' shop rich and faded.
Yeah, I mean the content is fine.
I mean I think I'd rate
it a six or a seven.
I think at this point you're
too small and you need
to try a lot of different
things quote cards,
zoomed in versions of the clothes.
I think you could mix it up a little bit.
How often is he posting India?
While I'm giving the answer
try to give me a general range.
- [India] Like once a day,
maybe like a little bit more.
- Yeah I would go with three times a day
to find your cadence and find your thing.
I'd rather lose 10 to 20% of my audience
to see if I can find the upside.
Ooh that was a really
strong, good piece of advice
for a lotta people on Instagram.
Let me say it again.
(warbling) That was me rewinding.
I'd rather lose 10 to 20% of my audience
by posting three times a day
if I was filling up their feed
and make sure you're being
strategic about those posts
and doing very different
things to maybe find pay dirt
as a thematic creatively for your upside.
I'd also start reaching out at scale.
You have products.
You're sellin' hats and
shirts and stuff like that.
You need to reach out all
day long, all day long
in the comments.
Go to Instagram, go to
people that have 5,000
to 50,000 followers that
are you know, got your vibe
as a user, and leave a comment
in their latest picture saying
I wanna give you some swag
can we do something?
You've gotta get more
distribution and awareness
and I would do that by giving away product
for them to give you shout outs
on their stream and siphon,
siphon their audience.
Cool.
- [India] Um, there's another...
- [Sid] (speaks quietly)
- What's that?
- [Sid] Matt is getting restless.
- I see Matt don't worry.
- [India] There's another question that...
- Sid the intern's getting
a little bit concerned.
- (speaking quietly)
- I saw him Sid but you have
to understand he works for me.
- [All] (laughing)
Not the other way around
but I appreciate it.
And more importantly
you should always know
that I'm seeing everything.
I see him, but I appreciate it.
- [India] Do you want
to do Lewis Howes' question
and then the last question
or the last question...
- Whatever you want India, let's go fast
because Matt's circling around.
- [All] (laughing)
- [India] Yes, I saw.
- Alright.
- [Voiceover] Jared asks
"if you have a business
"that is growing fast, is it more important
"to perfect the system and process
"or focus on adding more
people to the team?"
- Jared it's a good question.
I'm a big fan of both.
I don't understand why
not both, I do both.
As building VaynerMedia, I
was perfecting the system
while hiring people and training them up
and building out the team.
This is not an either,
or my man and this is
where I think people struggle.
To really be victorious, I
think you need to be able
to do both at the same time.
That's what separates the
women from the girls right?
The ability to be able to do
both things at the same time
and by the way that's
where hustle comes in.
Because you know what, to
do both you've gotta kind of
integrate the team nine to five
while kind of spending five
'till like two in the morning
to perfect the system.
This is where hustle matters.
This is where extra hours
in the day actually matter
because you can't get to both
actually, like physically,
you can't get to both and
so in a nine hour work day.
So if you've gotta business
that's growing fast,
first question is are you
actually deploying 18 hours a day
because remember too
many of you have missed
or are gonna miss your moment in time.
When it's happening, when it's happening
if you don't triple pedal down,
that's pedal on the metal,
like foot on the pedal, if
you don't go all the hell in,
all of it, if you don't
do that at that moment
you will regret.
You have missed your moment in time and
that is why I'm burning the
candle from both sides right now
because everything is
hitting a proper crescendo
as I'm going into my 40th
birthday in November.
VaynerMedia, Vayner/RSE my fund, cruising,
just cruising and the
#AskGaryVee Show cruising
you know just, family life and
health, I mean, cruising and
so I've gotta push harder
because you know what
at 42 I mean it might
just be that break and
that moment in time where
things aren't cruising as much
and so you've gotta extract,
you've gotta extract
all the value when you're
hitting that point.
You've gotta live it,
you just have to live it.
As a matter of fact, for all
of you that in your senior year
of high school that are watching
your show, squeeze the crap
out of that 'cause it's the best.
And college, you've gotta
squeeze everything all the time
and especially this
question really hits a nerve
because I want people to
understand the answer is both.
- Gary Vee what's up?
Lewis Howes here from the
School of Greatness podcast.
Big fan of the
#AskGaryVee Show keep it up,
love what you're doin'.
I've got a two part question
for you and it's geared
around selling books.
Now I've got a big book launch coming out
in October, in the fall.
It's called the School of
Greatness, very excited about it
- Good plug.
- [Lewis] and I've got
a two part question for you.
One with Instagram ads looking like
they're gonna be opening up here soon,
- Somebody's paying attention.
- and if you could only
spend money in one place
on ads Facebook or Instagram,
where would you be putting
your money on a book launch
coming out this fall?
That's part one and part
two if you were looking
to get 10,000 preorders
through bulk orders
where would you be focusing
your energy and efforts
to get 10,000 preorders
come through.
- [Gary] Piece a cake 'cause
I've done it so many times.
- [Lewis] That's the question.
Hope you like it.
Thanks for all you do.
- [Gary] I love it Lewis.
I would, I'm hedging here
because I just don't know exactly
what Instagram's gonna do.
If I knew that Instagram was
gonna fully open up the funnel,
the firehose and ads are just rolling in,
and we're seeing five,
seven ads a day on our feed
then I would say Instagram.
I really would 'cause I do
believe the attention is sitting
in Instagram the problem is my intuition
without any knowledge is they're
gonna be a little tighter
on the spigot and it's
gonna be a little tougher
to actually break through.
And so I would spend 50 cents on a dollar
in Facebook and Instagram.
The problem is your book's
coming out in October.
The ad platform's supposed
to come out in October.
My belief is it comes out later so I think
I want you mentally in Facebook,
Facebook's gonna dominate.
Number two's a piece a
cake 'cause I've done it
multiple times and I'll do
it again in March or February
for my #AskGaryVee book.
The place to go is to your homies.
What I mean by that is
reverse engineer everything
you've done for people
for the last 18 months
and send them one by one, not in bulk,
biggest mistake people
make is send a bulk email
and say this is the one time
I wanna send a bulk email.
You know I just need all
of you to buy my book.
I get that all the time, that
is a piece a crap execution,
it will not work.
I don't feel like it's
personal, I never buy but Lewis
when you email me and
you write a whole thing
like hey remember when
we first met in Ohio
and I drove you around, or St.
Louis, and I drove you around
and this and that and
you know thanks for being
on my podcast and hey
remember a couple months ago
I asked this question on the
show so here's my thinking
and hey it was great to see that.
Like real stuff, like real
stuff, like the party in LA
that I helped, like real stuff, real stuff
that happened between you and I.
Not a bulk control c,
control v, this is you and me.
You spend five minutes writing this email.
It would really mean a lot
to me, I'm gonna be guilted
into buying 100 books.
And that's it.
And you've gotta lotta people like that.
And some people are
even more homie with you
and they'll buy 1,000 or
they'll buy 40 or they'll buy 90
and literally when Jab,
Jab, Jab Right Hook came out
in that August, it came out
in February, in that August
or when did it come out?
In January, I don't even remember,
when did Jab, Jab, Jab,
Right hook come out?
Anyway, in that August.
Maybe December?
Anyway, in that August I emailed thousands
of people one by one, wrote
them one by one emails,
it took forever and I got a lot of sales
and well into the tens of thousands
so that's exactly what I would do.
I'd reverse engineer, CRM,
your whole social graph.
The 25 to 7,000 people
that most matter and one
by one by one remind them
the nice things you've done.
I know how you roll, you
build up leverage one by one
by one, one by one by one,
one by one by one.
Tedious, long but effort that
converts into actual sales
and follow-up.
I went in right in there be
like look you need to say no
in this email or, at the time
Nate who's the CEO of the book,
or Nate is gonna email
you and ask you every week
on the week and I'm cool
as shit if you go with no
'cause I get it.
Cool but you need to say
it 'cause I will bother you
until you tell me and
so put them in a corner,
suffocate them, don't let
them be able to just delete it
and not answer, pound them,
let them basically understand
that you will not have a
relationship going forward
if you don't at least answer
and that no is equally
as awesome as 1,000 and that's what I did.
I really made everybody
feel very comfortable
in saying no 'cause I get it
as I did with them being 1,000.
It's funny after I did Jab,
Jab Right Hook, even though
I did it for Crush It
and Thank You Economy
after I did it for Jab,
Jab Right Hook it's funny
I've been giving this advice
to a lot of people and
as you guys know we've been buying a lot
of hundreds and two hundreds
and putting them out
for Vayner.
So that's the scoop my man,
that's what I would do.
Guys, thank you for watching the show.
I really appreciate it.
My question of the day,
Lewis has got me fired up
for my book.
How many copies of the
#AskGaryVee book are you going
to buy when it comes out
in February or March.
Very simple question
not super complicated.
Please leave your answer
and lurkers, I'm talkin'
to you lurkers.
Here's what a lurker is.
We talked a lot about
it on Wine Library TV.
I don't bring it up as
much on #AskGaryVee
but I've been looking at the
data, there is a boatload,
a boatload of you who've
watched this show,
who've not commented.
I need you to come out
and at least say hey.
Please.
You keep asking questions.
This was a really good
episode, lotta stuff went on
in this episode.
Yelled at Sid the intern.
I'll keep answering them.
♫ Jab, Jab Right Hook.♫
(hip hop dance)